[Music]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
the department of labor announced this
week that 4.3 million americans quit
their jobs in august still waiting on
just one more
the head coach of the las vegas raiders
quit this week when it was revealed that
he sent a racially disparaging email
even though gmail tried to stop him
it was
really racist
it was so racist gmail detected it they
were like oh they detected it wait a
minute these aren't typos you sure you
want to it
and he clicked send anyway send this
send this to my buddy
i mean if nothing else that is brave
yeah
it was recently revealed that pablo
picasso's painting the blind man's meal
is hiding a nude portrait of a woman
underneath also hiding a nude portrait
of a woman underneath every teenager's
mattress
now
before phones right if you wanted to see
a naked yes
you had to go to a gas station and buy
a naked magazine you know you had to
have
that friend
or
that friend's uncle
yeah
but it was one designated friend it
wasn't all the friends you can't all get
the nudie magazine yeah
columbus day was this week
and it is just crazy that we still
celebrate columbus because everybody
knows
columbus was a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
columbus sailed the ocean blue
his dumb ass got lost in 1492.
we still celebrate him though we know
what he did
enslaved and killed people
women and kids
columbus was a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's an ugly little dude that we
celebrate even though he was a murderer
and full of hate
columbus is garbage let's throw him away
and celebrate indigenous people's day
columbus was a [ __ ]
columbus was a [ __ ]
new york's mta
recently started testing a new design
for its subway map and we have an
advanced copy
that is very accurate
leave me alone quite bothering me by
trains yeah i don't know well you don't
know where we're going you figure it out
you hop on or stay up welcome to new
york
former race car driver danica patrick
competed this week in the boston
marathon and obviously she won
that's not a pair
should have stopped her it should have
stopped her
but the car has a number car has a
number the car's registered i'm gonna
beat that car
it was recently reported that a teenage
girl in china lied about her gender in
an effort to join a boy band learn more
about it in mulan four the streets
[Applause]
would watch the butt off of that yes
i would watch that would have a
a party look the the
[Laughter]
it's a good show yeah and finally
wildlife officials in colorado recently
freed an elk from a tire that had been
around its neck for two years said the
elk somebody stole my chain
and that was the monologue did you like
the monologue
[Applause]
the weather is cooling down and the
leaves are changing which means it's
officially fall
it's also the start of another season
that you have probably heard of cuffing
season when singles try to get booed up
before winter now you might be wondering
what effects covet is having on the
dating scene during such a crucial time
well i personally don't know much about
it so to find out let's go to our
resident single person corinne wells
[Music]
thanks amber i'm karen wells reporting
live from these streets and out here
it's cuffing season the time of year
when you scroll through hinge to find
that perfect person to keep you warm
when you're too cheap to turn on the
heat
but
some people may feel reluctant to date
during a pandemic which is why i've
gathered some helpful tips on how to
cuff in covid
tip number one don't
what
do not do it cuffing season is a myth
like the male orgasm
i've never seen one
no one should participate in cuffing
season any more why not isn't dating fun
i thought people would be excited to get
back out there
fun
sure fun in the same way musical chairs
is fun but imagine all the chairs have
been peed on except for one and that
chair voted for trump
besides
cuffing season coming during covet
season is dangerous because of the risk
of spreading the virus no
because it's a trap which brings me to
tip number two
run it's a
trap
remember those dweebs who cuffed in fall
of 2019 expecting to end it in late
march of 2020 well they quarantined
together
and now they live in a tiny house in
central jersey with their newborn son
named breth
it's a conspiracy
maybe they were in love
love
love
cuffs aren't supposed to last
that is a hard and fast rule like no
white folks after labor day
that is not the phrase corrine it's no
white after labor day and it means white
clothes hmm
i i don't think that's correct
but you know what is correct tip number
three
just date people in your head
i mean look at me in my head i'm dating
chris evans
corinne have you even met chris evans
nope we've never spoken which means
we've never been in a fight which means
it's the best relationship i've ever had
yeah because it's not real
it's real to me
look if you're single during cuffing
season that is okay there is nothing
wrong with that and if you get lonely
just get a gravity blanket
gravity blanket feel suffocated by a
blanket instead of a human
now with all of that said my dms are
open korean get out of here
this is corinne wells reporting from d
streets
[Music]
in more serious news
former facebook data scientist francis
haugen recently testified before a
senate subcommittee she shared many
internal company secrets revealing that
facebook knowingly engages in unethical
practices these revelations have sent
shockwaves throughout the country when
asked about facebook's secretive nature
haugen said
that it results in more division more
harm more lies more threats and more
combat and this shocked a lot of
americans yet for even more of us the
reaction was
[Music]
da da da
doy doy doy girl who didn't know that
frickin door door door
you're saying something we already knew
but
francis haugen wasn't done she also said
facebook when confronted with a conflict
of issue between its profits and the
common good consistently chose to
prioritize its profits again some people
were shocked to find that out but
some of us were all like
[Music]
dipping
[Applause]
do it do it do it don't adore it
she went on to drop even more bombs like
saying in some cases this dangerous
online talk has led to actual violence
that harms and even kills people
oh
whoa that's heavy
yeah it is
wow
yeah
wow
[Music]
i didn't
i'm talking
do it
[Music]
you